well there's a new vaccination site up  and running in north las vegas take a  look you can find it here  at canyon springs high school which is  basically between alexander  and fifth street now we have some video  that we want to show you right now  organizers tell us  that the site just opened its doors last  week they're planning for about fifteen  hundred vaccinations  every single day if you're looking to  make an appointment you can find  a link on our website that's eight  newsnow dot com  well we know the disease is more severe  among seniors a pop-up vaccination site  opened today to make the vaccine  more accessible to those 70 years of age  and over hector mejia has more on this  program  from jerome mack middle school